former white house adviser steve bannon
facing criminal charges for refusing to
comply with a subpoena from a house
committee investigating the january 6
attacks on the u.s capitol bannon was
indicted on friday and two counts of
contempt of congress
mark meadows mr trump's former white
house chief of staff defied a similar
subpoena on friday
nicole killian is on capitol hill with
the latest nicole good morning hey good
morning to you jeff the select committee
says steve bannon's indictment should
send a clear message to anyone trying to
stonewall their investigation that no
one is above the law
former white house strategist steve
bannon is charged with two counts of
contempt of congress for failing to
comply with a subpoena from the house
select committee investigating the
january 6 attack on the capitol
according to the indictment bannon did
not produce documents and communications
and did not appear for a deposition each
count carries a maximum penalty of up to
one thousand dollars and one year in
jail there's a lot of noise out there
today ladies and gentlemen but remember
there's no whining no tears the
67-year-old trump ally is the first
individual charged in the select
committee probe the panel alleges bannon
appears to have played a multifaceted
role in the events of january 6 and had
specific knowledge about them including
this warning on january 5th
all hell is going to break loose
tomorrow his indictment comes as the
former president's chief of staff mark
meadows was a no-show for a deposition
friday the committee is threatening him
with contempt too stating it's
unfortunate that mr meadows has chosen
to join a very small group of witnesses
who believe they are above the law you
can't allow these
individuals who have information that
the committee needs to simply
flout their obligation
thumb their nose at congress and the law
meantime trump is facing more scrutiny
for comments he made in an interview
with abc news's jonathan carl
defending supporters who called for his
vice president's execution
you heard those chants that was terrible
he was you know the
he could have well the people were very
angry they're saying because
it's common sense
the select committee believes mark
meadows was with the former president on
january 6 and they say he has failed to
answer the most basic questions
including about his text messages that
day chairman thompson says he plans to
recommend contempt charges against
meadows as soon as next week jerica
all right nicole killian thank you